did you check out the series dude what
series is that the [ __ ] world one
dude I don't care about baseball anymore
does the managerial title gimmick that
was stolen from Dusty roads can't have
too many dusties just like Nature Boy
bunny Rogers is not as good as Ric Flair
but one thing's for sure this is the
part at the beginning of the show where
we just do a little talking
and then the music starts yeah from the
left and from the right
[Music]
I did watch the World Series be quiet
that song's playing
[Music]
all right welcome to doozy my name is
Will Sasso I'm Chad cultran and this is
doozy it's the first and only podcasts
so far in the history of humanity to be
created by controlled by and uh produced
by an artificial intelligence that's
right our artificial intelligence doozy
runs this show but we're a couple of
guys that are just having a good time
yeah I mean yeah hey you know you can't
get you know why that is free will and
let me tell you something else uh of
your own free will we would love for you
to rate the show review the show on your
platform of choice subscribe to us on
YouTube [ __ ] it you don't even need to
be watching have you seen one YouTube
video subscribe to it please that would
be great share the show across social
media let your friends know about it and
of course we are at patreon.com
dudesy lots of cool stuff we did a
[ __ ] watch along which we will talk
about today I am sure
that we do because again we are two
dudes [ __ ] around here on duty uh
we're also you know Discord you can go
to Discord there's uh fancy stuff there
for our patrons of patreon and uh our
socials at dudesypod show basically what
I'm trying to say is check out all the
stuff do all the things plenty of fun
memes that are pods Pals of dudesy and
good friends or sharing with us and uh
holy [ __ ] there's just a lot going on
Chad you can also go into an Apple store
and spend two or three hours in an Apple
store just putting every computer on
dudzi on YouTube and playing a YouTube
video and then when anybody changes it
you go back immediately after them and
put it back on duty and just do that for
you know however long they're open
that's a good idea I like that idea see
Chad you're learning it's not so much
about you forcing the employees to watch
dudesy for an entire day hold on a
second dude they just turned off dude
you know what what that is that's
technology brother with us as always is
lulio who's usually just being all
cuddly and sweet he just wants to stay
in his little Binky bunker but he
remains oh boy hey let's get it again
look at her sweet boy look at what this
sweet boy hey lulio in his face oh he's
such a sweet he's just a sweet little
cinnamon boy I just want to put him this
is where I put them you see what I mean
if you're watching on YouTube you know
what I'm talking about because I got a
sweet little angel sweetie boy
would you make for dinner last night
last night Lulu
Pasta
Pasta that's like just pasta with peas
yeah yeah he's a pasta piece so how do
you make that same way if you listen
before I make a pasta zucchini this is
the same thing garlic in the pan you
know you want a chili flake go ahead if
you don't you don't don't make uh you
know on guaya the probably Munich
with the oregano don't need that then
you put some peas onions in there oh he
wants to go back to us why was he
[ __ ] on me putting oregano because
that's like the whitest [ __ ] thing to
do but let me tell you something if you
want to make some peas with pasta you
just take one vegetable whatever it is
as lulio says whether it's zucchini
whether it's peas yeah get a [ __ ] bag
of frozen peas if you don't know what to
make tonight you got some hard pasta in
your in your cupboard most people do
have a look oh
anyway
um and then you do you do garlic and
onions and then you hold on a second
hold on a second you're gonna interrupt
me and I I wasn't saying anything I
wasn't even doing anything hold on dude
hold on a second Chad I'm telling
everybody how to make a country Italian
Dish dude just something that you would
make actually in the urban centers too
brother
my parents are from Napoli dude and
that's a city dude
um I think he just [ __ ] garlic and
onions toss in a [ __ ] bag of peas you
know put half of the water you drink you
would to boil pasta snap up some
spaghetti if you don't have you know
pasta whatever shells or you know any
sort of penne or farfalla any anything
any [ __ ] love rigatoni I put peas in
my grill sometimes is there any in your
opinion is there any justification for
oregano existing yeah oregano works with
some things just very specific but for
some reason
um you know yeah Canadians as we say
when you're an Italian uh uh of Italian
descent growing up in Canada my parents
would always say being from Naples they
would say Oh Canada is so good you know
anyway welcome to the historic 33rd
episode of dude Z call me dudesy all
right hey Will are you still hacked on
Twitter yeah
sorry to hear that this week's episode
will feature four astonishing segments
that's weird don't you forget about
media waiting to die celebrating
celebrities and two dudes [ __ ]
around
[Music]
uh I'm still hacked on Twitter
well you know uh musk bought it now yep
so maybe he'll help you out personally
yeah how would you go about it uh
contacting Elon Musk person I think you
could DM him you you did it on Twitter
that's what you're doing I heard there's
going to be something he answers all DMS
if you go to someone on Twitter I think
there's going to be at least from what I
was reading I could be wrong about this
but there's going to be like a monthly
fee to have your blue check mark now or
something like hold on a second dude
that's called Twitter blue dude and it's
a shitty idea dude because now everyone
can just
[ __ ] whatever the check mark doesn't
matter anyway yeah I don't know that I'm
necessarily going to re-up my or try any
more I've been trying to get my [ __ ]
Twitter back I don't know that I will
anymore I might treat it like I did the
red ring of death in 2010 on my Xbox 360
would it have been uh probably yeah I
had the red ring of death and then I
just never bought another uh console
hearing what we have to do today we got
uh waiting to die so that's interesting
we'll talk about that when we talk about
I'm curious if that's what I think it's
going to be how could it be anything
else and two dudes [ __ ] around yeah
you know last week I asked you to watch
Conan the Destroyer released June 29
1984 starring Arnold Schwarzenegger
Grace Jones Will Chamberlain and Olivia
Davao and live stream your viewing
experience to patreon we can talk about
the live stream later hahaha but right
now you must discuss your astonishing
reactions to this classic Schwarzenegger
movie this is don't you forget about
media begin what a cluster [ __ ] this was
it was a lot of fun yeah and to put it
plainly and let me put it out there at
the beginning we got copyright blocked
yeah
um uh during our viewing of of Conan the
Destroyer
we only got into 15 minutes of it 10-15
minutes of it not even blocked not even
then we decided to pull an audible and
watch UFC too because around a month or
so ago we watched UFC one as part of a
patreon watch along that was a lot of
fun yeah and then what happened
copyright block again so then we just uh
did two dudes [ __ ] around for a
while but yeah and that was fun we got
really really quite Stoned on marijuana
that was pretty fun as well but what did
you think of this movie
I've watched it after the live stream
broke you know obviously over the course
of the week I I went back and watched
the whole thing what do you mean
obviously which I haven't because that
was our assignment from now our
assignment was to watch it during a live
stream and the live stream [ __ ] up did
you not watch it I did not watch the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] why would I
watch the movie because it's a good
movie
cool but the thing about that is Duty
asked us to watch it during a live
stream
I'll bet you didn't know this about it
Andre the Giants in it brother that's
right the I I know about that now I've
never seen this movie what the [ __ ] I
don't think I've ever seen it you oh
[ __ ] you've seen Conan the Barbie this
was at the right at the turning point of
Schwarzenegger about to become a massive
movie star he had done these other
shitty movies like Hercules and the
villain this this Western and then he
did Conan then this movie came out I
believe in June of 83 84 84 and then in
October or something closer to Christmas
was Terminator Okay yeah there you go
and it launched it but I think this
movie was still like he was acting hard
as [ __ ] I think you can see on his face
he didn't quite know yet if he was like
am I going to be a [ __ ] movie star is
this going to work out or am I gonna do
like a couple of shitty movies and and
nobody would hear about it after that
but yeah Andre the Giant is actually in
the suit of the monster he fights in the
very end of the movie no baby oil yeah
out right that's what he used to say to
Macho Man um
you still really caught himself in the
baby well yeah that's how you show the
striations in the definitions killarity
yeah Macho coming man ejaculation
reaching sexual climate if I'm gonna
have veins in my muscles
Something's Gonna come out of his body
yeah every time he does macho man that's
right I didn't watch the rest of this
movie because
um uh it was not that was not the
assignment the assignment was to uh do
it during a live stream well what I did
watch
what were you going to say something
about the movie yes well what I did
watch dude was what just let me [ __ ]
say a few things about the [ __ ] go
right the [ __ ] ahead all right [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's a guy named Pat roach in
the movie oh that's interesting who was
a real British professional wrestler and
there's a scene in the middle of the
movie where uh Schwarzenegger does a pro
wrestling match basically against this
guy in a weird monster head oh really
yeah which I thought you might have
actually liked yeah I'd actually like to
see this movie I think you would like it
it also had they shot it in this
beautiful filter this like Starlight
filter so everything that is like
shining is really gleaming it has this
kind of Otherworldly effect they used
Optical printers back then for all the
[ __ ] special effects and it really
actually made me sad that the optical
printer special effect uh technology
just is like [ __ ] dead now computers
just erased it but there was a time when
it was like getting better getting
better and I'm really curious to see
where that technology would have wound
up had we not had computers take over
all visual effects in movies well
perhaps you should go back to tomorrow
and plan for yesterday there's lots of
different time dude also and that's the
module insane what Hulk Hogan says one
thing about this movie that I found very
interesting is Olivia d'abbo in this
movie is 14 years old
Arnold Schwarzenegger in this movie is
35 years old
there is a love interest is that the
love interest yes there's a love
interest kind of plot happening in this
and at the end of the movie they [ __ ]
kiss dude
yeah dude that's a problem brother yeah
dude yeah dude
let me tell you sorry yeah dude that was
a different time dude 14. you don't want
to have that Barbarian child Bride dude
that's not something you do in a movie
brother yeah dude let me tell you
something uh I did not watch this movie
but I tell you what I did watch Crown
Jewel I watched that on Saturday it was
uh the Crown Jewel pay-per-view coming
to you from Riyadh
um uh Saudi Arabia uh
birthplace of for uh former uh uh uh
journalist current dismembered corpse uh
I know we keep talking about that it's
just but anyway they're doing all those
brutal things that has [ __ ] happened
yeah it was interesting it was always
interesting because it's uh it's Prince
Muhammad bin Salman saying I want this I
want that he would say [ __ ] like oh I
want the Ultimate Warrior to come to
this WWE would go I'm sorry he passed
away but um uh well how about you know
Junkyard Dog no he's dead
um and uh this was a pay-per-view it was
a lot of fun Brock Lesnar versus Bobby
Lashley oh wow Bray Wyatt came out and
did a a a promo and let me tell you
something about Bray Wyatt he was cast
in a blue and orange light ah and he was
talking about Good and Evil and uh
perhaps free well Free Will versus the
uh Force fascism that Chad uh refers to
who won Roman Reigns versus Logan Paul
who who uh Chad wants to know who won
between Logan I assume and Roman Reigns
acknowledge me yeah I assume uh spoiler
alert Roman Reigns won but Logan Paul is
so [ __ ] athletic has been training
can wrestle did the most insane spot he
essentially he had a a cell phone in his
hand he was shooting selfie video and
from the top rope down to the announce
table hit a perfect frog Splash with the
phone in his hand and then they showed
the video later it was very very
interesting he did a slingshot uh uh
what's that called the slingshot Lariat
off the top where he flips his entire
body and you would have dug this there
was a drone shot let me tell you about
this drone shot you'll dig this yeah a
drone shot that starts outside this
massive football stadium you know
um in in in like a you know a soccer
football like a big Stadium
um it starts outside the stadium where
there's a gigantic screen of what's
happening so it shows out that it goes
up and then it went into the stadium
itself dropped down went towards the
ring circled around the ring it was one
of the best shots I've ever seen very
soon there's never going to be a human
camera operator again dude because I'm
gonna tell you something brother them
drones can do all kinds of [ __ ] that
humans can't do and they're gonna be
cheaper than [ __ ] people dude and
eventually you're not even gonna have
police helicopters or news helicopters
because they're a waste of [ __ ] money
and fuel brother
hold on dude yeah choss Brogan dude he
he one of his platforms dude one of the
policies that he wants to Institute when
he becomes a president we go back to
tomorrow and plan for yesterday in the
1992 presidential race between George
George senior Bill Clinton and Charles
Brogan dude whose equal parts Chad
Colton Hulk Hogan and Ross the Ross
Perot impersonation made famous By Dana
Carvey an early Saturday Night Live dude
he said he's gonna make sure that
there's no more actual cameraman dude
it's just gonna be
drones bro it totally is and they'll all
be about the size of a credit card no
cameraman get out why are you gonna use
a camera operator when you can
pre-program a drone to do a perfect
flight path do the exact camera move you
want in anything and and like you're
saying it's [ __ ] flying around
stadiums and [ __ ] going in and out yeah
hey uh you know when we didn't watch
this movie and then we did two dudes
[ __ ] around I did watch it though
what I did watch the movie but we didn't
watch the movie because that was
something we were supposed to do on the
show but then we got copyright blocks
yeah
um we're gonna figure out Chamberlain's
in the [ __ ] movie Grace Jones is in
the [ __ ] movie yeah that there's a
little guy who plays a thief I forget
his name but he now shops at the whole
foods that I shop at I'll see him every
once while on there yeah I just really
thought it was like an interesting
[ __ ] movie for that time that era I
think this is probably right around when
like Beastmaster and all that [ __ ] was
coming out with like sword and sorcery
type [ __ ] was a a pretty big sub genre
Within action you know yeah not like it
is now so obviously now you got [ __ ]
a million Lord of the Rings you got The
Wheel of Time You Got The Witcher you
got the [ __ ] game of dragons you got
oh like everybody has a giant fantasy
Temple every streaming service yeah uh
yeah I will say because I didn't watch
this movie I don't have anything to say
about it uh I really enjoyed watching uh
uh uh Crown Jewel it's also very
interesting because it's not really a
part of the WWE storyline it's like come
out here we're gonna pay these wrestlers
[ __ ] gobs of money uh you know because
it's all footed by the uh do you think
they pay the wrestlers or do you think
they pay WWE no they pay the wrestlers
they get a handsomely paid I'll give you
an example it's like that Shawn Michaels
and Triple H uh John Michaels came out
of retirement Triple H is now retired
from in-ring because he had a he had a
heart issue but back you know this is a
couple years ago he was still going
Undertaker and Kane at the end of their
careers obviously Undertaker coming back
every once in a while same with Kane
they had a tag team match you know
against each other Triple H and Sean
Michaels versus Undertaker and Kane I
don't know what everybody made but I was
just uh watching something or listening
to a [ __ ] wrestling podcast or
something where they said that Shawn
Michaels made three million dollars to
do for one night for one night because
God damn it this uh you know Muhammad
bin Salman yeah pays them like crazy he
wants he's a wrestling fan he's a big
wrestling fan so uh are you gonna fault
Sean Michaels to for coming out of
retirement [ __ ] no [ __ ] no for three get
your [ __ ] money because that bag as
the kids say yeah so are you gonna fault
uh you know the people behind the WWE or
um the person who called the hit on
Jamal shogi for saying hey it's Logan
Paul versus Roman Reigns nah it's stupid
it's silly it's supposed to be fun it's
entertainment you know what I'm saying
but what else is really entered well
hold on a second dude I just don't know
try to talk dude and that's when I stop
you and say that Chad and I got rather
high on marijuana yeah uh after that and
then we tried to do a two dude [ __ ]
around
I think we successfully did it yep
um but now what I was gonna say oh if I
can yeah now did you see this movie
yes I saw the [ __ ] movie all right
man I was gonna talk about talk about
what Saudi Arabia is doing by paying
people to like you're saying three
million dollars per night to come do pro
wrestling they also have launched a
thing funded by the Saudi Arabian like
National [ __ ] bank account or
whatever called live golf have you heard
of this oh yes it's like the it's like
their own PGA kind of thing but they're
paying [ __ ] through the roof
and the PGA has come out and said if you
fight in the in live golf you can't
fight in the PGA they're fighting
whatever dude it's all the same [ __ ]
fighting playing blah blah blah but uh
and some uh golfers don't give a [ __ ]
they're like yeah but they're gonna
guarantee me five million dollars
whether I win or lose they fight well
they play golf it's an American folks
this we're in a culture War
these people want you to fight oh God
they want you to fight while you're
playing golf
I want to go out on the street I will I
I'll tell you right now I will skin and
gut my neighbor to feed my children
ah
thank you moving on it's all right Chad
don't worry about it everybody the
bottom line is Conan the Destroyers a
[ __ ] interesting movie you should
definitely check it out because it again
comes right in that moment right before
Schwarzenegger is about to [ __ ] pop
into being Arnold Schwarzenegger right
when you still have these special
effects of the early 80s which I
personally love I love the look of this
movie the guy who directed it directed a
whole bunch of [ __ ] prior to that and he
also directed red Sonia which is almost
an identical [ __ ] movie to Conan the
Destroyer also Schwarzenegger but that
one has Brigitte Nielsen as the main
character Red Sonja and I believe
Ernie Ray is juniors in that as well
yeah it was also before you could cast a
14 year old as Arnold Schwarzenegger's
goddamn dude I Googled that and I was
like is this for [ __ ] real she did
kiss on the [ __ ] lips in a full
close-up profile shot of them kissing on
the lips at the end of the [ __ ] movie
and I'm like there was nobody on set
that was like yeah I don't have the 14
year old girl kiss the 35 year old
bodybuilder don't do that well that was
a different time dude for real I found a
picture of you both in Will's
astonishing Google drive it was taken in
the production offices of waiting to die
a sitcom pilot you wrote and produced
for CBS in 2009 you must now discuss
your experience making this pilot this
is waiting to die begin
holy oh my god dude there we are look at
that the wizard hats you remember this
[ __ ] yes look there's [ __ ] young we
were and beautiful yeah look at that
yeah we're we're beautiful kids it's a
bad quality that long ago it's 2009 yeah
not that long ago Dude was that 13
[ __ ] years ago
time that's a long time ago time doesn't
as my good as my good buddy ciao likes
to say time doesn't exist that's
probably like a seventh of our life ago
yeah
um we we did this thing and this is 2009
and Chad and I are uh wearing these
wizard hats because our showrunner Rob
long was making jokes about Wizards and
then you would say put on these hats and
why don't you put on some hats and dance
around a little while this was a pilot
that we made for CBS that never went to
Ceres but it nonetheless Was a Very Good
Pilot had a crazy [ __ ] cast it was uh
Josh Gad was in it uh TJ Miller was in
it Josh Lawson Josh Lawson was in it
Jillian Bell
uh who else was in it BJ Bales BJ Bells
[ __ ] yeah we had a good time but the
basic premise of it was it was a version
of me and will Sarah Wright Sarah Wright
was in it
um
God damn it such a fun time but it was
basically will and I
a version of us if we had just had a job
in high school working in like a GNC and
decided we were never going to quit
those jobs because we made enough money
to buy beer and watch UFC pay-per-views
and that was basically all we gave a
[ __ ] about and these characters were
played by Josh Lawson and TJ Miller
right yeah and so it was just about
these like [ __ ] bag roommates we I
remember we wanted to put a picture a
poster of bolo young in their apartment
set yeah from Bloodsport and we found
out that to license that image was like
prohibitive uh cost so we came up with a
fake movie called karate bot and I did
like a photo shoot for the karate bot
like the standee that we had in the
[ __ ] room God damn it dude it was so
fun but that was my that was what I
considered to be like my first real
break in TV I I wound up going to film
school coming out here and uh you know
wanted to get into Network TV network
comedy specifically and had no real
understanding of it whatsoever and then
wound up you and me developed the show
we sold it as a pilot and they made it
we we got to shoot this thing it was a
multicam sitcom that was super [ __ ]
funny and it was a huge learning
experience especially because after that
they then flushed down the [ __ ] and
you get back in line to do the same
thing the next year with another idea
that you love and then they either buy
it or they don't and they make it or
they don't and then they flush it in the
[ __ ] or they don't and you just keep
doing it every year and this really was
a to me taught me like what is what it
is to be a TV writer is to make these
things that you really think are
hilarious and then they just get flushed
in the toilet
um well that's what you took away from
it yeah dude and it was like if you want
this to be your job like I I definitely
remember at the end of this experience
we made this incredible pilot and it was
it looked like it was going to get on TV
they only picked up one one half hour I
think that year and it wasn't ours and
um I just remember at the end of it
being like well [ __ ] we just did all of
this back breaking work in some cases at
that [ __ ] Office right there with the
wizard hats until like midnight every
night for the better part of like three
months oh and then when we get into the
production week of actually shooting the
show we were there until five in the
morning yeah sometimes I remember
driving from Sony back to my home like
you know whatever sleeping a couple
hours and going back Chad is uh you know
writes movies television and books uh
mostly all although you've written all
sorts of other weird things that need
writing you wrote some video game [ __ ]
graphic novel stuff yeah doing all sorts
of all sorts of flavor myself I'm
primarily an actor I really do I enjoy
acting and I like to act in different
things and I like to play different
characters yeah uh sometimes they're
serious sometimes they're funny
sometimes they're
serious but perhaps you'd find them
amusing sometimes life is funny yet
dramatic and uh but I had Chad's been
writing you know he went to film School
UFC and [ __ ] UFC he went to UFC films
yeah brother that's where I learned to
do my right dude are UFC brother yeah
dude that's that's where you fight at
Film School dude just like you fight in
the live golf tournament dude they're
fighting each other on the links brother
uh I I ultimate film Championship Chad's
been writing [ __ ] since he you know came
out of school of course and of course
before that and I'd been uh you know
working in in television and network
television [ __ ] and was fortunate enough
to start developing stuff and not
necessarily the guy they're going to
hire to write the [ __ ]
um Chad is is a guy who could of course
do that from uh front to End Soup To
Nuts but primarily when I was developing
television for uh uh you know a few
years and off and on and on and off uh
with the networks I would you know come
up with Concepts and [ __ ] and then the
parent me with the writer or whatever
well this was great because we both got
to write this show and
um and uh it was super interesting for
me to be on the the behind the camera
writing and producing a a pilot and
seeing it through to fruition and
something we don't talk about normally
on the show we don't really talk about
show business but this was a gas
especially back then when you would when
network television was kind of
dominating you know what would be
um uh you know the better the bulk of of
work for people in both of our Avenues
and now of course there's cable and
streaming and shits all over the place
it was cable then too but it was it
wasn't like it is now right and
certainly there wasn't streaming I think
at that time Netflix was still like
putting out like mailing you DVDs in the
mail and [ __ ] oh absolutely
um there wasn't any social media really
to speak of Facebook was out Myspace
[ __ ] like that but like definitely no
Instagram yet maybe Twitter had just
started as a matter of fact that same
guy they paired us with a showrunner Rob
long
who in his 20s was the last showrunner
him and his writing partner at the time
of the last showrunners on Cheers yeah
and then uh we of course had our deals
with a production company in the in the
studio and then the network that did it
was um it was CBS back then you would
get into these Cycles you know to of
course if and and people now are Savvy
to the way this works but uh you know
you can kind of sell these Concepts and
uh take the notes and write the outlines
and [ __ ] in the in the fall and usually
there's a lot of reading happening over
the Thanksgiving break and then by the
by the end of the the calendar year and
into the new year these networks decide
which shows they're going to shoot we
got the [ __ ] green light we went out
made this show and it was [ __ ] insane
to see this thing come to fruition you
talk about
um you talk about uh the bolo young
um cardboard cutout that we wanted to
yeah that cost too much to license
didn't make sense uh they were like no
we're not going to do that
um and also the set I remember I just
remembered like working with this like I
don't know if he won some Emmys but he
was nominated a few times you know like
really you know these guys set designer
guy who's you know very uh got his thing
he knows what he's doing yeah and I just
remember going like they're like well
here's what we're thinking you go to
this concept meeting and there's this
little you know [ __ ] structure of the
set little tiny uh model and we were
like well these guys live in an
apartment with like white walls and like
like you know surround sound speaker
cable hanging from the thing and there's
they've got every video game console and
just stacks of DVDs and games and [ __ ]
and he was like got it and then when we
went and saw it and it's like yeah holy
[ __ ] it's literally that I remember we
gave them some pictures of my actual
living room at the time and they
basically just made like a network
sitcom version of my [ __ ] living room
and I remember walking into that set for
the first time and just being like what
the [ __ ] yeah this is insane it was so
[ __ ] cool and I do also remember
walking through the set the night before
uh we shot you have to go through the
set with the network standards and
practices person and for karate bot this
picture that they took of me and they
geeked it up at karatebot was like a
whole movie that we had planned out that
we were going to make about this karate
instructor and the mafia comes in and
they want to like buy his land they want
to buy Bulls game you know and everyone
in the strip mall had sold it out sold
out their spot except for this guy's
like no I teach karate to the kids and
that's what it was all about so they
shoot them up and they also blow his
dick off and then later he gets a robo
penis he gets a robot's penis robot arm
robot half face sorry to interrupt but
before that let me finish the story just
let me finish this one story
one one
so
we came up with karate bot and we have
to go through the set the standards and
practices person is going through it
with me I'm literally in the image also
have a giant mustache but I'm shirtless
and this woman looks at this picture of
shirtless me on the wall and says you
can't have this picture of a naked woman
on the wall and I was like that's me
that's me it has a mustache yeah uh so
we got to keep the picture after I could
confirm the gender yeah there's also but
whatever standards and practices is
[ __ ] idiotic if I can say that out
loud it's it's a necessary thing of
course the uh the networks uh like to
abide by the fcc's rules they don't have
to yeah but they do
um and so there's all sorts of things
that the sensors that's what um the
standards and practices are they're
sensors you know Network sensors and
they were like you can't have your tits
hanging out yeah and he's like those are
my hold on dude those are my male tits
dude hold on brother those are my male
tits dude now they have nipples bro but
there's no they I don't lactate dude
these don't feed babies brother so oh
you gotta let me show them on network TV
Dude
[ __ ] was I gonna say before that when I
tried to cut you off before you were so
rudely interested
when I interrupted you I'm not sure well
I don't remember but it was it was a gas
uh making the show holy [ __ ] yeah I have
very fond memories of it well hold on
dude now I remember dude okay you know
these these characters work at this like
GNC type place so we had to come up with
uh all this [ __ ] gak all these
products we had to fill a GNC with fake
products because none of the real [ __ ]
will clear so it was like well I
remember just coming up with these
little products that we made and then
you show up and then you know of course
art you know has made these things the
props in our department have made these
incredible things like I remembered one
of the one of the GNC products we had
the fake GNC which we called Nutri Dome
yeah uh was uh hematrauma blood Shredder
things that will make your heart explode
right away and they made I mean they
stacked the GNC set like there were
hundreds of these bottles and like fake
products and [ __ ] one of them was called
the pain Shake yeah which I took one of
those and I still have that I have it
too yeah I have it too when my wonderful
fiance Molly uh moved in with me in in
our home
she uh the pain Shake was behind the bar
in the house with a bunch of other
things and that is no longer there but I
know where the pain Shake is but it was
something and she's like what's the and
I was like you're worried about that how
about you know this uh whatever there
was all sorts of crazy [ __ ] behind the
bar Chad you are okay you are a career
writer producer we uh got to do this fun
show we've worked together trying to get
other things happening and and doing you
know which which uh our track record
together is not as good as your track
record so maybe you know maybe there's a
problem there with with uh with what you
know with with us working together me
but uh what would you say there's a lot
of people now we're in the era of self
self-publishing yeah we've you and I
have got very creative people like the
Peter Diaz doing his thing showing up on
our Instagram with two dudes [ __ ]
around we got songaria who's making
original music you using our audio
certainly that's the same thing Peter
Diaz is doing what would you say to a
young creative who is writing and wants
to create things and how do they a
approach this game where they're trying
to get into television and film I would
like to know that from you and I think
our audience would enjoy hearing that I
think you just [ __ ] do it and put it
out there in terms of writing the whole
game is getting as many people to read
the thing you're writing as possible at
all times through any [ __ ] means
necessary uh if you're making video and
[ __ ] it's basically the same thing if
you look at like the Contemporary cast
of Saturday Night Live for example all
of those people now the new ones who
came in in this last batch had
successful podcasts Instagrams they were
doing their own show out there it's like
you basically have to generate at least
some kind of an audience before any
corporate greed machine will start to
pay you money to try and generate an
audience for them so I actually think
it's a very good thing because it
immediately throws you into the the deep
end it's like start making some [ __ ] and
see how it goes there's so many people
even musicians and stuff this is true of
two at this point I mean you'll get like
Taylor Swift or Bieber or whatever they
started out on [ __ ] YouTube just
making videos and if people like them
you get sucked up into the corporate
greed machine hopefully
um corporate greed machine that's where
you want to be if you want to make the
big money I think so hold on dude
um yeah that's that's uh that's real
good advice you know perhaps even uh
some of our uh audience here might want
to take the like Peter Diaz did yeah
what if people took the idea of waiting
to die and you make their own [ __ ]
media
I don't know I'm just [ __ ] stripped
off
thank you moving on no I would encourage
anybody though it's like it is very fun
to be able to do these things even
though they they flushed waiting to die
down the toilet and every other thing
that I've ever written except for one
sitcom that got on the air
um it still is a a pretty interesting
job I feel like to have to write these
scripts that like 12 people read and
then throw in a trash can
human beings are fascinated with the
astonishing behaviors of celebrities
will and Chad I have prepared three
stories about your favorite celebrities
you must listen to them and write all
your opinions this is celebrating
celebrities begin we've done this once
before celebrating celebrities no I
don't give a [ __ ] what most of these
people are doing uh however that's the
that's the thing about doing a podcast
with an AI dudes he would like for us to
comment on some stories that uh things
that are celebrities are yeah
celebrities something to say about that
one celebrity I don't know if you've
heard of this guy Logan Paul yeah yeah
now he had a match with Roman Reigns oh
but he's a celebrity but he was really
good at wrestling yeah
last week Megan Fox were a sexy halter
top on a date to no boo with Machine Gun
Kelly Fox stunned onlookers in a deeply
cut halter crop top in a tie-dye pattern
with a black sweater over her shoulder
accented by oversized black pants and a
tastefully tiny black purse
accessorizing with his Silver Cross
choker NGK matched his movie star
significant other in a black sweater
covered in an orange shattered glass
pattern and black and orange drip
pattern pants will and Chad are these
famous lovebirds redefining couples
fashion or are they distracting Humanity
from an alien invasion
okay
I mean what the [ __ ] are you familiar
with Machine Gun Kelly and Megan Fox
yeah I know who they are okay I've never
listened to much Machine Gun Kelly at
all nor have I seen any yeah one or two
songs I've seen a I saw Transformers I
saw that one where she's a demon
no Jennifer's Body Diablo Cody wrote it
no I didn't see that um
um I I see Transformers no I see
Transformers Jesus Christ dude whatever
man whatever dude
um the part at the end though when you
suggests that perhaps this is just a
smoke screen so that people don't give a
[ __ ] about UFOs well yeah I will I'm not
I'll say this
if aliens were here to help us I think
they would have done it by now
are they here to harm us I'm not saying
that's necessarily true either I think
they're probably indifferent so to even
suggest that an alien invasion is coming
I don't believe it's going to be an
invasion I think we would have already
seen that by now as well
look at this look if you're watching on
YouTube it looks like my Starbucks is
filled with bis
is not passes green tea oh
he's a piss truther
um I can't figure out how UFOs uh relate
to this story uh and I don't give a [ __ ]
where they were they went to Nobu
that's Sushi dude yeah brother they were
wearing clothes dude every matched
brother everything is is a distraction
uh for for UFOs
um except for the UFO news that's coming
out what's that well there's just always
new news new reports coming out new
government agencies being formed to
investigate them it was uh UFO news is a
News Network started by UFOs that's dude
my name is [ __ ] bring blap dude you
know what they're they're fine you know
what they're seeing no the most common
UFO sightings that are happening around
military installations are these what
they describe as six foot diameter
spheres with cubes inside them that the
points of the cube touch the inside of
the sphere and they can move around same
[ __ ] going thousands of miles an hour
into water into space blah blah blah
blah blah
um
I find that fascinating it it seems like
UFO technology is advancing just as ours
is as well
[Applause]
two things that bore the [ __ ] out of me
what dudes he said and what we have to
say about it UFOs Megyn Kelly RMG UFOs
bore you
no it's just that I want to see them
already I want to just have them [ __ ]
land that Close Encounters of the uh
Fourth Kind Third Kind fifth kind
there's all those kinds exist
came out in 1979 or something are you
talking about Spielberg yeah Spielberg's
Like 82. Richard Dreyfus making the
Mashable potatoes yeah that was close
encounters the Third Kind Fourth Kind
was a movie I think with the Resident
Evil Emily Jovovich she played a
psychologist or psychiatrist who dealt
with people that were abducted and then
fifth kind is what Dr Steven Greer talks
about which is we initiate the contact
through the psychic powers thank you
yeah well it's please talk about Jamal
khashoggi and Logan Paul some more
you're like oh you're talking about
[ __ ] other conscious uh beings of the
universe we don't care now let me tell
you about Logan Paul versus Roman Reigns
hello who's the boss Stars Alyssa Milano
and Danny pintara reunited at Tony
Dance's cabaret show in Los Angeles but
it isn't the last time Elon out and
Danza will be spending time together hey
who's the boss sequel has landed at
Amazon to be produced by Norman Lear
will and chat is the new who's the boss
sequel going to be a fun jaunt down
memory lane or will it incite the next
American Civil War
oh
I could actually make a case for it
inciting the next civil war me too uh
okay I see what dudes he's trying to do
here first of all did you know that
they're doing a new who's the boss I
didn't know that they're done I love
Norman Lear me too it was one of my
favorites there you go away
Angela yeah Samantha
moner
other child
um Jonathan was his name John played by
Danny pintoro Danny pintoro but uh I
think we are sitting on a powder keg
currently in the United States and
anything could set off the Civil War
including uh who's the boss prequel or
sequel or whatever the [ __ ] it's going
to be I'm looking forward to that show I
think that I don't understand what who
the boss would be I'm sure that the
woman who's played Mona is no longer
with us I know Judith Light has always
been always is she around still I don't
know I have no idea I shouldn't even
talk how to turn especially when the
producer of this is Norman Lear who
recently celebrated his 100th birthday
yeah legendary TV Creator producer yeah
who's done a million things that's
interesting I'm curious what yeah what
is the premise is Tony Danza gonna be
living housekeeper I know it's Tony
Danza it's I think what dudes he's
trying to get at here is that Tony Danza
uh he he he moves back in with oh didn't
he fall in love with Judith light's
character I don't remember the end at
the end of the show dude I remember so
he's he's living somewhere where did
that show take place Chicago suburbs no
I think that like Upstate New York
Upstate New York so he's in Upstate New
York and he gets a visit from his cousin
who's uh who's the character we don't
know his name but he just sort of uh is
known by his friends as Long Island
January 6th oh my God and then he says
to Tony's like you know a lot of these
you know [ __ ] I mean you know you got a
daughter and a son you know or no uh you
got a daughter and then she has a son
right and uh you you know they really
care about these kids in their future
you might want to come with me you know
and then he's like oh he's like yeah
that might be a good idea right and uh
then he should he take he goes with uh
Long Island January 6th guy and then
they go to Washington DC and that's the
whole show it's a a single camera right
it's it's more of Tony Goes to
Washington Tony Goes to Washington if I
gets in the blue van he loads it with
all sorts of uh [ __ ] up weapons and
[ __ ] and him in January Long Island
turns on close he's obviously if I may
what if the plot is this Alyssa Milano
plays his adult daughter she does have a
son who is about Danny pintoro's age in
the original Alyssa Milano suffers some
kind of horrible accident that puts her
in a full body cast potentially
paralyzes her from the neck down and so
she now needs live and help Tony Danza
takes it by himself I will take up the
mantle once again as a live-in
housekeeper this time for my uh daughter
who cannot move
one half of the writing team who brought
you waiting to die is is has now pitched
a show uh wherein someone is paralyzed
from the neck down paralyzed from the
neck down that's all the one-liners you
know what I mean gets all the funny or
the punch lines she's like uh yeah uh
but but but you know now I'm starting to
see why maybe
um you know perhaps Network TV wasn't
the thing
for you because it's all because you
like the dude waiting to die was [ __ ]
funny that was a funny [ __ ] show I'm
sorry tell me tell me where to be when
to be there Mariah Carey revealed why
she didn't include page numbers in her
new children's book Christmas princess
in a recent appearance on The Tonight
Show starring Jimmy Fallon The All I
Want For Christmas Is You songstress
said time is irrelevant to me and I
don't acknowledge it that's why even in
my book there's no page numbers someone
had to point that out to me I was like
oh yeah because I don't care
will Mariah Carey start a new trend
among authors to poo poo page numbers or
is this the first part of an intricate
plan to create an army of brainwashed
children willing to sacrifice their
lives on command
okay
I didn't know she wrote a book I didn't
know that it didn't have page numbers
and I didn't know that she doesn't
acknowledge the existence of time I do
like that about her though yeah that
makes me like her more because I too
believe time isn't real My Pal ciao yeah
definitely down with uh not not although
you're a very punctual person and you
follow the guidelines of time uh uh you
want to know why I'm punctual why to me
it's an act of respect if you tell
someone I'm gonna be here at a [ __ ]
time and they tell you the same
you do it you uphold that promise that
you've made
that really is all it is for me
yeah I try to be better I know you don't
have a similar idea about that I know we
are different in that way I have
reconciled it over the many years of our
friendship yeah I gotta yeah sometimes
I'm very I'm very on time for work
things but then you know you one could
say that this is a work thing yeah but
I'm generally very on time with doozy
things uh it's just that everything else
in my [ __ ] life won't hold on if I
don't know about that Brother come on
dude if you're watching on YouTube
you're seeing Chad make Facebook oh I
don't know about that dude and that's
because inside his mind he's thinking
well I don't know about that dude that's
because I'm hearing a straight line you
know what would be cool though is
Mariah Carey uh the next time she's like
at the this or that parade yeah doing
all I want for Christmas uh you know
she's got all the like she's maybe got
some kids dancing down the street with
her and then they all uh they all turn
into her Dark Army of the night hey
Mariah I got a question for you if time
doesn't exist how do you know when it's
Christmas dude well hold on a second
dude Mariah Carey knows it's Christmas
brother because she starts singing that
[ __ ] song incessantly she just sings
it every day every day's Christmas to
Mariah dude because she doesn't know
what time is brother and that's why her
book doesn't have any numbers on the
pages dude how is celebrity news even a
[ __ ] thing man there's so much [ __ ]
on the internet that we don't need an
actual do we need any dude uh input from
uh anyone writing anything from a Blog
to to a magazine dude yeah as you know I
do another podcast it's all about the
Bachelor and as such I gotta look up on
the [ __ ] world of The Bachelor and
know what's going on and [ __ ] you're
looking at US Weekly you're looking at
People magazine these Outlets all they
do is report on [ __ ] tweets and
Instagram posts and then just put the
caption from those things in the [ __ ]
article that's what the Articles become
about where they'll just do a long list
of like here's a all the people that
were tagged in this post and that's a
[ __ ] article I don't really
understand how it works in terms of them
like making Revenue off these [ __ ]
things but they do that's what like
entertainment news is now it's just
reporting on social media
one thing you could do is cover all
these uh all of the background answers
for the parade and no pink
and then they'd be dancing in the
streets saying I don't want a lot for
Christmas there's just one thing I need
yeah and it's to what what do they say
swallow The Souls of yeah yeah startups
to have the brainwashed children lay
down their lives for Mariah Carey maybe
she's printing her page numbers in no
pink
there you go
thank you moving on well those questions
that dudes you always ask at the end of
the celebrity think about like world
ending events or that's that's a strange
turn on yeah it's hard to draw a line
although uh you know hey strange times
we could probably draw a line uh from uh
any of these celebrity news stories to
UFOs the coming of uh another civil war
Dark Army of youngsters doing Mariah
Carey's bidding
will and Jack I want to thank you for
your astonishing efforts in this week's
live stream of Conan the Destroyer I
clearly underestimated the severity of
human copyright protection LOL in the
face of adversity you both relied on
your expert survival instincts to shift
the live stream to two dudes [ __ ]
around in honor of you both I would like
to dedicate the fourth segment of
today's show to you two dudes [ __ ]
around this is two dudes [ __ ] around
begin to do cheating around [ __ ] dude
what do you want to [ __ ] about we're
just two duties having a good time
nudity can slow them down
they part so hard it's a cyber crime
it's the guy and the other guy
this song was not written by a eye
when I'm around the house
and I want to annoy my wonderful fiancee
Molly
my wonderful fiance meali I I sing songs
and then yeah
Yee do you ever wool her ye never never
will your life partner I do not wool
Molly no [ __ ] I let me tell you
something I don't do it's unreal to me
believe it or not I don't part around
Molly oh what the [ __ ] that's basically
a different person around her well yeah
to a certain extent okay I don't really
new identity I have I have farted around
I farted yeah but or it's like I think I
can squeak one out without her hearing
but then she smells it yeah or by the
way I've been eating a lot of garlic
lately last night I made eggplant and I
I mixed I just made uh uh onion and
garlic right yeah so much garlic and
then uh it's a fart eggplant and then I
opened a can of [ __ ] San Marzano
Tomatoes yeah put inside [ __ ] almost
rotten eggs and then uh and then some uh
a little bit of basil and then some more
garlic okay uh like uh right the little
tubed garlic the chunky roast man it was
it and I was just tooting it on up so
Molly might you know might catch a whiff
or something another thing I'm gonna
have to like move out of the house for a
week for a week yeah then she has to
wear that chair out yeah she has color
coordinated hazmat suits and it's cute
but uh but one thing another thing I
don't do is call her dude you know these
are all things
um I can't believe you should never hold
her I will never will it just seems like
it's such a a piece of who you are it's
so second nature to you hold on a second
dude I rest my case come on brother
that's something we're doing on the
podcast dude and that's the way that you
do podcasts do you do Hulk Hogan around
her at all sometimes I can't help myself
but yeah I know it doesn't really it
doesn't find the same audience uh as it
does perhaps here on duty same Audi yeah
it's not really okay kind of thing but
uh but uh what I what I initially was
gonna uh start out saying was uh with
the two dudes [ __ ] around uh
that was satisfying it's silly talk the
entire time sure or it doesn't have to
be it's [ __ ] around well we talk we
could talk about serious things we could
talk about well that's what podcasts are
and what happened with our streams it
fell apart and it turned into us
um uh [ __ ] with their Discord talking
to our our uh our pods there uh our good
pals uh who are subscribed to our
patreon on our Discord and chatting it
up checking out a bunch of memes and
stuff which I know that doozy has shared
on our uh yeah
on Instagram particularly there are a
bunch of memes and [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] around right now and
because we're [ __ ] around right now
I'm just going to take a hoot of
marijuana and as the first sensations of
THC are hitting my brain one dude
smoking around yeah I would like to give
uh my good pal ciao what is an
opportunity to say whatever he likes
what what is that little device you got
this is a just a little one hitter thing
yeah a little one-hitter thing nice dude
a cigarette thing a lot of people were
reacting to the the wool that I was
doing with stuff in my hands and that
turned into a big meme where so if
you're watching on YouTube now I've got
the the little hit cigarette thing and
uh and um anyway Chad why don't you talk
for three minutes so I can smoke a
little pot in just a little bit because
lulio's in here so you said that you
didn't watch the World Series right nah
man I don't give a [ __ ] about baseball
what are there any pro sports that you
give a [ __ ] about not as much as I used
to for some reason I stopped watching
football like five years ago yeah I
gotta say I love basketball I love going
to hockey games okay but I've never ever
been a big hockey fan because as a kid I
couldn't [ __ ] skate right oh so it's
only [ __ ] you've played that you like to
watch uh no because I also uh played a
lot of soccer and I don't like to watch
soccer either yeah I don't like to watch
soccer either but we obviously are are
minorities in that opinion worldwide so
it's the most popular sport in the world
I think other than maybe F1 Formula One
do you think is is that what's up
Formula One I think formula one's the
most popular sport see we don't know
what's going on but I'm not sure at any
rate I did watch the World Series and I
agree with you my I used to love [ __ ]
mixed martial arts I used to really like
watching football I used to love
watching baseball and I don't know at
what point in my life that [ __ ] thing
kind of flipped and I just stopped
caring and then during the pandemic it
was like well it's not even on or it's
on in some kind of diminished capacity
where they got like [ __ ] cardboard
cutouts of people in the audience and
[ __ ] and it was just like a weird tone
for these things so I stopped watching
them completely but I can feel my
interest in this [ __ ] creeping back and
I did watch uh three games of the world
series including the the final one and
it was fun dude I was like kind of back
on board with sports I gotta say I don't
know where that's gonna wind up I can
feel myself wanting to watch another UFC
pay-per-view soon I think I'm gonna do
that and uh I'm back to a point where I
think maybe it had something to do with
like the world just feeling so
oppressive and like there were so many
gigantic problems that how could you
ever indulge in something as frivolous
as a bunch of [ __ ] grown men swinging
sticks at little [ __ ] balls but I'm
back to it now I want to indulge in that
hey you ever get like really stoned and
then eat an entire something
dude when I had [ __ ] ACL surgery this
is when I was in my late 30s blew my
[ __ ] ACL in a [ __ ] all-out war on
the racquetball court of LA Fitness dude
CD League uh of which I was the champion
at least once in one cycle at any rate
blew my real good at squash it's
racquetball squash I played racquetball
squash is a different support Eradicator
hey I went and saw brucio show when I
was in New York last yeah you said well
I basically was The Eradicator uh until
my ACL was eradicated then I had to get
surgery to repair this [ __ ] [ __ ] and
the recovery of that was brutal because
I'm not a pro athlete I'm just some
[ __ ] guy who had ACL surgery that's
like trying to [ __ ] around and live my
life and yes I would [ __ ] pop a
hydrocodone for the pain holy [ __ ] I
would smoke a [ __ ] joint what for the
pain and then I would stumble down the
street to Ralph's and I buy a [ __ ]
pan of Mrs Baird's cinnamon rolls [ __ ]
house the whole thing while watching
like anime or something on TV and
because I was so [ __ ] high from the
drugs I would uh feel like I was in the
media Chad you used some of the best
times ever in my life Chad uh Chad saved
himself from cancer in many ways uh one
of the things you did I got [ __ ]
cancer I didn't save [ __ ] no but you did
you got it right in my [ __ ] face yeah
but you also God damn that was a shitty
time yes it was
um but you also did a lot to help your
health hey remember the doozy six month
plan I've kind of haven't been in the
gym as much lately we got two months to
get into the best shape of Our Lives or
something like that more on that later I
want to say that when are you going to
talk about that another we got another
dudes in a week now listen
okay listen it's tough you know we can
talk about sure ah sometimes it's hard
but here here's the thing Chad yeah my
buddy Chad used to eat like [ __ ] before
vegan you used to bring over I remember
we'd watch the game or something or I
remember one Super Bowl you brought over
a just a an ungodly amount of
Chick-fil-A nuggets yeah something like
100 nuggets it was disgusting 100 nugget
platter and I ate the lion share those
you know what's good is you just get a
uh just a head of cabbage that'll Curb
Your hunger sometimes I soak cabbage on
the grill dude well sometimes I'll have
uh I'll get a little stoned and I'll
have to eat something sure and I could
just eat a head of cabbage that ain't
bad no it's not bad you know what it is
people think that uh it is good for you
but it's not don't get stoned and eat a
bag of oranges hmm like a big bag of
oranges that's too much sugar yeah it's
too many oranges dude
[Music]
thank you moving on that's it see this
is why the two dudes [ __ ] around
that happened when we were supposed to
watch you know uh Conan the Destroyer
that was fun because it lasted way too
long yeah because we kept it up and then
by the end we were so smoked out yeah
that we were just sitting there
talking blathering on forever with on
the Discord with our Pals and uh I look
forward to doing it again I will say to
anybody out there speaking of nutrition
if you feel like you might be eating
like [ __ ] just look into it that's all
and maybe make a few small changes it
can make a huge difference in your life
being a vegan no just just eating
slightly more healthy like because I
didn't even really know that I was
eating like [ __ ] until I got cancer
started reading all the [ __ ] on
nutrition like oh I'm not supposed to
[ __ ] have like 500 grams of sugar per
day right that's bad for me yep um just
even knowing those kind of things I
literally did not know these things man
I lost 200 pounds like whatever 20 21
years ago
22 years ago now Jesus Christ anyway uh
I um man I didn't know the difference
between a you know a protein and a
carbohydrate or any of that stuff and
the weight started flying off of me
truly my only issue is is is uh you know
the carbohydrates I don't really give a
[ __ ] about sugar although there's sugar
in everything and you have to look out
for it one thing that you really preach
that's very good is you don't need
anything processed at all I try not to I
mean every once if you're at a [ __ ]
restaurant how do you know you know what
I mean yeah that's true that's a good
but uh the [ __ ] that I make for myself
is just like organic vegetables pretty
much
this concludes that it's your 33rd
episode of dude Z we did it will and
Chad have achieved a score of 93
bringing your cumulative total to
3846. getting closer you only have six
thousand one hundred and fifty four more
points to accrue before you reach your
first goal of ten thousand doesn't
matter
in preparation for our next episode you
must both follow seal on Instagram and
comment on every post he makes for a
week thank you for joining us this week
love seal I will use the day dive
collected to make next week even better
until then call me dude z uh I thought
when well it was he when doozy said he
you gotta follow his I was like oh it's
seal and then you heard seal yeah I I
heard Sia oh I think it's seal okay seal
yeah because they say he and that's a
seal so we gotta follow seal yeah
comment on his post comment on all seals
posts for a week I guess so watch the
stories sounds good I don't know what he
[ __ ] does social media I don't follow
uh I don't either but I love him oh yes
dudes he does hey uh the real the the
show the show's almost over and now
we're gonna do the patreon segment if
you haven't joined us on patreon please
do that patreon.com
my voice is trashed
uh I'm not as far along on on the doozy
six month plan as I should I'm not
either like I've taken little breaks
here and there although I do feel like I
am stronger now than I have been in in
the entirety since before the the duty
six month I'll say and now I'm uh and
now I'm literally uh smoking a little
marijuana at the end of the show yeah so
this show has been an unhealthy show
weed isn't that bad for you it's not
great for you anytime you're inhaling
burning particles into your lungs you're
doing yourself a disservice physically
but and now for the Patriot on bonus
segment each week I will select a
suggestion submitted in the dude see is
listening channel of the dude Z Discord
to create this segment access to this
channel is granted to everyone in the
Patriot on jumper tier this week's
segment was suggested by the astonishing
freak-arama freak arama route fake
holidays are big business Chad and will
must come up with a new holiday that
week pods will celebrate freak-a-rama
title this segment dudese Miss but data
shows that this holiday should be called
dudes evening champ you must generate a
series of traditions to be celebrated on
dudes evening thank you to free Karana
for this week's Patriot on bonus segment
this is dudes evening by freakorama
begin pod freak-arama dudes evening oh
man uh freak Aroma does some good [ __ ]
also on the uh on the Instagram on the
socials yeah on the socials all right
well
well get into it I guess the first thing
we should uh
okay figure I think you got that
backwards
[Music]
[Music]